[Musique]
gérer c'est le délai si c'est vrai bonne
journée à toi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'on a découvert que j'étais
schizophrène un trouble mental chronique
qui causent des hallucinations visuelles
et auditives
je ne serai jamais normal certaines
personnes se contente d'entendre des
voix
bonjour moi je les voir d un super mec
j'ai dû changer d'école m'appelle maya
wada chine usant pour intimider et
certaines mais finalement je pense que
tu es inoffensif tornade comme cuisine
j'étudie pour devenir cher qu'est ce que
tu as un problème avec le contact visuel
tu dis toujours exactement ce qui te
passe par la tête
il vaut mieux dire exactement ce qu'on
pense ou ne rien dire du tout que je
t'ai vu pour la première fois j'ai pensé
peut-être qu'il est juste original et un
rien à social mais est autre chose de
super cd je sais pas trop quoi répondre
à ceux qui ont été démasqués
répétera-t-elle liban
et
on fait comment
et je sais aussi que tu te sens seul
pour coter
non
enfant elle cancer les gens ne demandent
qu'à réaliser tous les souhaits qui peut
avoir mais quand on est schizophrène
les gens vous traite différemment c'est
pour ça que tu l'as pas 10 parce que tu
croyais que j'allais m'enfuir
[Musique]
je vais continuer à avoir des visions et
entendre des choses n'existent pas
[Musique]
la banque n'a pas donné une chance de
rester et tu l'aurais pas fait je t'aime
il faut laisser les autres découvrir les
ténèbres que l'on cache en soi parce que
c'est eux qui vous diront ce qui est
réel quand vous ne saurez pas quand même
[Musique]
je suis là
depuis quelques jours
[Musique]